I got scanned this with a clickbait
title at all because it's 100% true true
story if you've seen the unboxing that I
posted a few days ago during that entire
unboxing video I was super suspicious
from the very start this is not the
handiwork of an original unbox iPhone I
just want to tell you and fortunately
for myself but fortunately for everyone
else in the world
I am extremely naive and I want to
believe that there is good in the world
and everyone is nice and kind and they
would never just willingly screw someone
over but no am I kidding this is the
Internet that's what's the most
contradictory you thought that you could
ever have
there were so many telltale signs that
the 3d s on that but the setting was
factory-sealed
was in fact not battery field at all
there is a very common theme in the
comments and most of you guys who
especially or Apple fan said just dude
why did you not watch everything Apple
pro's video I missed that one and I wish
that I would have seen it because it
probably wouldn't be here making almost
same exact video that evening thankfully
though I did spend as much money as he
did on the phone I only spent $450 and I
know you're saying only but he spent
thousands only to find out that it was a
scam repackaged to be sold as brand new
I should have known that it was too good
to be true because I was like wow 450 I
think that's a pretty good deal for a
perfectly factory sealed 3ds from 2009
let's go through the top things that I
found that proves the subtlest not what
it said it was number one the box was
terribly filled in my feeble minds naive
heart and one thing the thing that
everyone in the world is good I was like
well maybe it's just because it's gold
no not because it's old because somebody
refilled it my one main concern though
is
after doing of these simple searches it
is actually we're really easy to reseal
a box and then make it look like it's
new what you wear the job with making it
look like it was new bro but I was past
it this is what we came for
I moved on I moved on to number two now
it's nothing else this was a huge red
slide for me I like this can't be
there's absolutely no way that Apple
would have made this mistake they would
never ever ever do this these people are
liars
there was a terribly placed screen
protector over top of when I opened it
and not only that was a perforated
little line they credibly made it seem
like this was some sort of a roll type
thing and they just threw it down ripped
it off and on you go I wanted to believe
number three is this something that
looks brand-new
no like super scuffed there's
fingerprints on it
but yet I still wished to believe number
four there was a very small detail the
one that was just another red flag just
were using itself in front of my face
[Applause]
what's that
it's an people SIM card ejector this was
placed rather strangely wrapped up with
the headphones I also thought was very
weird because Apple is very particular
about everything you that they do you
everything has a place and most of the
time that I can recall this will always
neatly wrapped inside of here on the
same note of the SIM card I like that's
weird this little cover seems to be
super scratch that's strange
I'm actually going to see if there is
anything in here okay there is there is
still some card a brand new phone that
has never been opened would not have a
scratch cover like this you see it it's
very faint actually smell that faint at
all it's like a huge - number six this
is something that completely slipped my
mind
in the timeline of Apple history so I
guess it worked I'm going to not use
iCloud I think if we can't remember what
I did yesterday so the fact that I
didn't remember when iCloud was
originally announced it's not really a
surprise to me and they come subscribe
to you guys because I'm clearly a huge
Apple fan so
is something that I feel I should have
realized I know if that disciple came
out in June of 2009 the first mention of
iCloud was either like flashing flashing
in front of my face is the answer it
really no iCloud in 2009 there was no
iCloud into October of 2011 to 14 years
a huge oversight on my part and you
thank you so many of you guys who
actually pointed that out right away
and last but not least be one final
missing link to focus piece to find out
if this bone has ever been activated
before is putting in the serial number
or the IMEI number online and it will
tell you if your phone has been
activated before and if it hasn't been
activated it would not say valid
purchase date you could say phone was
inactivated actually would say I never
said being a little bit overdramatic
right now this is I've been talking this
isn't Justine I just seen is dramatic
she's over the top well she gets upset
about the product this is what uh I feel
like I am the real-life version of
unikitty from the lego movie like that's
me honestly I just figured it out I'm
unikitty guys it gets better like
honestly I wish that just in the end of
my video and you might wish it was too
but guess what it's not because I would
like to walk you guys through the
conversations that I've been having with
my eBay seller oh yeah so in my world of
unikitty Legoland I was thinking wow you
know what I'm gonna give this guy the
benefit of the doubt he probably bought
it and thinking that it was new and then
he like wow I'm going to resell it you
know I'm not so sure that's the case at
all
so in the eyes of scene world where
everyone is perfect in kind and everyone
loves each other and would never be a
fraudulent scammer I asked the guy so
hey I was just coming buddy here we're
doing guest it's going from and he says
I need to read it verbatim
I bought it from one of the cell phone
stores cell phone stores okay they're
wanting to believe having faced mistake
number one two three one through eight
he doesn't video by two three years ago
from a store and it's a collectible item
indicating why do you think I bought it
you think I bought it because I was
like I have for $50 that I would like to
just buy something that's in a box for
fun is essentially what I could do yeah
I know what the collector's item
he then proceeds to tell me that it only
has value if it is filled and unopened
okay once you open it and it doesn't
have any collector value and it is
highly undesirable so that house
collectors items work Wow
continues to sanity purchased from a
reliable store and cannot figure out why
I would have opened the box exclamation
point exclamation point what was the
purpose of opening the box he said I
have the iPhone two three and 3ds
although I purchased from stores and
tested as collectible items and he sold
all three even bought the new iPhone 7
from the same store and never had any
issues well you didn't have any other
issues because nobody else opened the
boxes
did they anything do but it clearly they
work as goon maybe Apple knowledgeable
with me or all of the Apple fans that
watch my videos I need a drink
so I wrote back and detailed everything
that I just previously said in this
video and he's acting a little sassy
I thought that I wanted a mint-condition
3GS on it doesn't matter why I opened
the box or what I wanted from this phone
like you advertised something and I
purchased it as advertised
what is the use of a mint-condition 3GS
opened in your hand
apples don't support this phone anymore
and almost all carriers are on 4G it's
actually really been a very true
statement so you get one point before
buying this item I weight tested this
product and it was accurate and yeah if
you're going to weight test I mean I'll
be honest with you
this phone is in very very good
condition so out of all the things that
had happened it's a great phone it's
good it's just not what I was expecting
like I was a hundred percent lied to and
I take these things very very very very
seriously I bought the original iPod on
eBay there was no issues because I
bought this as
is I knew it is been opened I've never
had any other issues on email before
this is the first time that I've ever
run into any type of issue and I think
the best thing about eBay is they do
have a money-back guarantees so buyers
really end up always winning so I'm not
worried about that I'm more concerned
with anybody else who tries to buy a
futile iPhone don't make the same
mistake that I made
don't make the same mistakes and
everything Apple Pro made I think that
just means I need to watch a few more of
his videos so it's for me thank the tips
from him and be careful out there
because in the world of unikitty and
iJustine everyone is perfect and nice
and kind and harmless but that's not the
real world again at all all right want
to play zelda so at least I got I love
you guys I'll see you later
nice this video is the extra special
because I'm going to be importing all of
these amiibo into Zelda breath of the
wild then at end of which is officially
out so to celebrate I'm going to get
really well now I did this yesterday but
you can only use an amiibo once per day
I kind of ruin my chances of filming
this yesterday this time I'm going to
take documentation and we're going to
see